Allen John Pollock author of the
Pretender and a note back in the back on
page 260 you say in response to a letter
asking questions about Martin Frankel or
David Ross or Rossi Ross a spokesman for
mr. Iacocca's office said that she could
not comment because he does not remember
mr. Frankel or anybody by that name nor
does he remember the information that
you were asking about something about
the private jet what is right well at
some point Marty Frankel who was this
incredible scamster was in communication
with Lee Iacocca through a mutual friend
and he was trying to get Lee Iacocca to
sign on to his scheme and to participate
in a charity that Frankel was trying to
start to shield his fraudulent scheme
from the world's eyes and he actually
offered mr. Iacocca the use of a private
jet and mr. Iacocca flew around in this
jet mostly in Italy for about two weeks
but mr. Iacocca
was smart enough never to really you
know sign the on the dotted line
and get involved with Frankel but what
was interesting about the note was that
at that point Frankel was going by the
name David Ross and Iacocca said he
didn't recall the name Marty Frankel but
the note doesn't say anything about or
the response to my note doesn't say
anything about whether he recalled the
Dame the name David Ross which was the
alias that mr. Frankel was using at the
time and so you think he really mr.
Iacocca never heard anything about an
airplane oh I'm sure he did I mean he
rode around on the airplane and I'm sure
he knew the name David Ross but what he
what what his spokesperson said in the
response was he didn't know the name
Marty Frankel
well in the early part of your book and
we will talk about mr. Franklin just a
second it says cameo appearances Robert
Strauss former chairman of the
Democratic Party and ambassador to
Russia his pictures in the book right
how does he play a role in this book
well again at one point Frankel in an
effort to cover over what he was doing
tried to create a charity he said he was
going to acquire a bunch more
our insurance companies and he hired mr.
Strauss's law firm to represent him and
he met with mr. Strauss and mr. Strauss
his apartment and mr. Strauss have set
it up so his said that akin gump would
represent mr. Frankel's interests Jarvis
chose based here akin gump right a law
firm here right how long did they can
Gump represent Marty Frankel
it was the representation stored it mr.
Strauss and mr. Frankel met in May of
1998 it was Memorial Day weekend they
met mr. Frankel's apartment at the
Watergate it was sort of a holiday
weekend and very soon after within days
the arrangement was set up and they
continued to represent mr. Frankel
through the end of the year maybe a
little bit into the end to 1999 cameo
appearance Jimmy Carter former US
president well mr. Carter dodged the
bullet on he was at one point supposed
to me with an emissary of mr. Frankel
and perhaps with mr. Frankel himself I
think mr. Carter mr. Carter's people at
the Carter Center thought that they were
had planned a breakfast between between
I guess they were used they thought the
name was David Ross and the former
president because mr. Frankel had
offered to give a lot of money to the
Carter Center and this breakfast was set
up it was going to be attended by father
Peter Jacobs who was the president of
this phony charity and it the breakfast
never took place
in your book you have a couple of
pictures of a man named Martin Frankel
this is the one I want to ask you about
right here where is this man today he's
in prison in Rhode Island
he's awaiting trial he'll be tried next
October in federal court in New Haven
Connecticut when you see this picture
what do you see an ugly guy with the
glasses why are the glasses not the way
they are well that picture was taken
after he'd been in jail for a time in
Germany he was caught in Germany it was
ninety nine four months after he'd fled
the u.s. he was in Hamburg it was Labor
Day weekend or right over
on that point he was he was kept in a
prison there they didn't quite know what
to do with him in Germany they weren't
used to sort of picking up at that point
internationally known criminals and he
was in a in a prison with a bunch of
drug addicts and smugglers sort of
low-level criminals and he kind of
didn't look so good when he when he came
out for hearings this picture that is
Frankel going for one of his first court
appearances in New Haven Connecticut
after he was finally brought back to the
US he fought very hard to stay in
Germany to anyone who would listen he
would talk about how in Germany he would
get a short sentence for the crimes he
committed in the u.s. he was going to be
put away for life that was tantamount to
you know to capital punishment it was an
affront to human dignity and he tried to
make this huge argument that it was
almost immoral for him to be extradited
to the United States
the Pretender err on the cover fooled
the financial world and led the feds on
one of the most publicized manhunts in
history how did you get to the point
where you thought there was a book in
this story well when Franco um fled the
u.s. in 1999 um it attracted a huge
amount of attention nobody knew who this
guy was until he fled and it quickly
became apparent that he had stolen gobs
of money
nobody knew really how much the real
amount is probably about two hundred and
fifteen million but at the time he fled
it looked like it might have been a
billion dollars and he had apparently
stolen it from a bunch of southern
insurance companies that specialized in
selling burial insurance and the
remnants of stuff they found in his
mansion which was caught fire shortly
after he left was just fascinating it
looked like he'd involved the Vatican it
looked like he was interested in
astrology it looked like a harem had
lived there and it just sort of caught
everybody's interest because the scheme
had clearly gone on for the better part
of a decade and it was an incredibly
wild story and as I worked on it it just
it became sort of too enticing to give
up it sort of had
everything and had money it had sex that
had the Vatican it had some interesting
names and I thought it said a lot about
business and human frailty not to
mention greed and and human frailty was
sort of the felt he was sort of the big
thing that attracted me to the story
have you met Marty Frankel I met him
once I met him in Germany and he asked
me for money
where was he he was at a hearing um he
was uh there was a hearing he had he was
accused of some tax violations because
he had supposedly imported diamonds and
two into Germany illegally and he had
also used false passports and so I
walked up to him at a hearing told him I
was doing him doing this book he seemed
very excited that he someone was writing
a book about him and then at the end of
the hearing I handed him my card and I
said I want you to write to me and he
said send me money like very savagely
and I said well I'll send you stamps
because you know I wasn't going to pay
him um so I sent him about six stamps
and I never heard from him but I've
heard that he's very angry at me why um
for a variety of reasons he was very
very secretive he was very secretive
about his personal life and his
professional life and they sort of
melded together and I think when he got
back to the US he started hearing that I
had talked to pretty much everyone he
knew that I'd sort of unraveled how we
did the financial scheme and one of his
arguments is you know that the amounts
of money have been exaggerated and I
think it's pretty clear that the amounts
of money have not been exaggerated and
that he is completely to blame for the
trouble he's in how old a man is he
he is 47 I think and he's in prison
right right now in Connecticut right he
hasn't been convicted of anything yet
not yet what's he'd been charged with
he's been charged with a bunch of things
including racketeering racketeering
conspiracy securities fraud wire fraud
initially he was accused of money
laundering which is a lot of what he did
but because he wasn't extradited on
those
charges he's not going to be prosecuted
on those charges and where will his
trial be held in New Haven Connecticut
in what court in federal court you have
a picture in here of his parents right
did you meet them or do you talk to them
I did not meet them
his father died about a year and a half
before he fled his parents are were by
all accounts lovely people one of the
odd things about Marty Frankel is he was
obsessed with money but in fact he was
brought up very modestly he was brought
up in Toledo Ohio his parents were not
acquisitive people they weren't
materialistic people they lived in a
very modest home his father was a
magistrate and divorce court
very well-respected in the local bar and
his mom worked for the city of Toledo as
a clerk and they were a family that was
very interested in learning very
interested in knowledge and and study
they were also athletes you know amateur
athletes and they had the son who in
seven respects followed suit he was
interested in studying and he studied
everything from ancient religions to the
financial markets and when he became to
the financial markets he became obsessed
and he would have to sort of picture
this guy you know the sort of very very
nerdy guy he's the guy who sat on the
back of everybody's high school class
and everybody wondered what's going to
become of this guy he is such a social
misfit and he sat in his room for the
most part he didn't go to school parts
of the time he was very school phobic
very afraid of taking tests and he
studied how much education does he have
he has that's a hard question to answer
because probably even he doesn't know he
went to the University of Toledo for
years but because he couldn't take tests
he'd never got a degree I mean he
probably took you know enough courses
plus you know you know double enough
courses to to graduate but he had a
million in completes he just couldn't
take the test
so when did it start it started in um in
the late 80s he got a job as a broker
for a small brokerage firm run by a guy
named John Schulte on and immediately he
ran into problems for two reasons
one was that he could not bring himself
to trade which is really one of the most
comical aspects of this is that here's
this guy who by all accounts really did
know a lot about the financial markets
but he couldn't get himself as he would
say to pull the trigger he would you
know identify a stock he wanted to buy
and then he just couldn't do it he was
just paralyzed and all his own mean all
his short life he's been equated it to
his test anxiety and in fact it is very
similar so he he really wasn't doing
much at the brokerage firm and then he
had another problem which is he fell in
love with the boss's wife so here's a
picture here in the book of the Shull
tees and they're their daughters the
fellow John Schulte where does he live
today John Schulte lives just outside of
Toledo
he runs a I guess you call it a carry
out a convenience store
how about his wife Sonya Sonya is living
in North Carolina I believe she was as
of recently and she is awaiting trial
with Marty Frankel what she charged me
she is charged with racketeering and
securities fraud she's been accused of
helping him really all along the way on
the is she one of the things she did was
create false statements false account
statements Frankel was supposedly
trading the assets of these insurance
companies he owned through fraudulent
means and he would send them account
statements every month or so and they
were all frauds because he couldn't
trade anything and Sonya is accused
excuse me of of creating those
statements there's a picture here of Jon
Schulte standing outside of the company
and it says up there on the Billboard
the truth is now known write Jon Schulte
is a very unusual
person he is um he's sort of maniacal he
is a man who holds a grudge and when
Marty Frankel ran away with his wife
that you know that account will never be
paid um what year did that happen that
happened in I think it's 86 really quite
some time ago and the man is still angry
to this day he is really really mad and
um in the next few years they were sort
of a battle on who was going to rat out
who first was Frankel going to get the
SEC to come after John Schulte or was
John Schulte going to get the SEC to run
to go after Franco and Frankel and Sonia
the wife one in in in the late 80s
John Schulte was accused of violating
securities law for the way he was
running his his brokerage firm and in
fact did a little bit of time in a
federal penitentiary but they also
accused him of molesting his daughters
and he was acquitted and when he was
acquitted because this got so much press
in Toledo was such a widely known case
he put up that sign outside his
brokerage firm saying the truth is now
now did Sonja and Marni Frankel ever
marry
they didn't she helped him through a
variety of early of his early schemes
first he set up something called the
Frankel fund and then he set up
something called the creative partners
and especially with creative partner she
was at his side and eventually they fled
Toledo and they moved to Greenwich
Connecticut and their circumstances
really changed he ended up owning two
mansions in Greenwich on and she at
first moved to Greenwich with him and
then she I think got fed up with the
very weird scene at the mansion as he
sort of started experimenting with sort
of strange sex and and eventually tried
to distance herself from him moved to
Norton moved to Florida and then North
Carolina married somebody else but every
month or two she'd come back to work on
those statements she couldn't there you
know there's a lot of evidence that she
really wanted to sever
with him she she just she wanted to get
rid of him but she is she told one of
the other people who have actually pled
guilty in this case he has too much on
me and she couldn't get away by the way
how many people have pled guilty I'm
trying to remember now I think about six
or seven people have pleaded guilty
serious crimes yes some serious crimes I
mean some you know it's lying out to the
FBI over you know cars and stuff like
that but Frankel's bodyguard was just
sentenced to ten years in jail for
racketeering and money laundering
related David Ross that's David Ross why
did he Marty Frankel use the name David
Ross throughout your story well that's a
good question and he would give you one
answer and I'll give you another his
answer was that and he told people this
constantly was that he was running away
from John Schulte he thought John
Chelsea was going to kill him I mean
again this is ten years after the
divorce he still thought John Schulte
was going to kill him the real reason is
probably more complicated and that he
was banned from the securities industry
in 1992 after his first fraud which is
the Frankel fund and so he had to
operate under an under some names and he
used you know a handful of them and
David Ross was the last one he used you
have a picture in here of one of the
mansions in Connecticut right actually
is this the one you open the book with
uh it is that's where the fire took
place what happened
well after Franco left in a hurry on and
he left instructions for a couple of the
women who were left in the mansion to
shred documents and they had three
industrial-strength shredders waiting to
eat up all the incriminating evidence
and the women got bored shredding I
think shredding documents is a tedious
affair
and so they started burning the the
evidence in fireplaces and the fire got
a little at a hand I mean it wasn't some
of the early press accounts it made it
look like the mansion was up in flames
in fact it really was just sort of a
smoldering fire that set off fire alarm
and when the security service called and
wanted a password the women didn't know
the password in fact there was also a
lot of looting after he left all the
people he gathered around him who were
doing clerical work and taking care of
his computers and driving people around
they just looted the place how long have
you been to wall street journal' almost
13 years where did you come from
originally I was the editor of a
publication for lawyers and work for the
American Lawyer magazine which is a
magazine about lawyers before that are
you a lawyer I'm not I would pass this
one but I'm not where's your hometown in
New York on where'd you get your college
Brandeis University in Massachusetts
what got you interested in being a
journalist and doing that story like
this in the first place
um I'm nosy I'm nosy and I like to know
how things work um
I think I'm just naturally a gossip when
was there a nosy person in your family
before no I am the nosiest person in my
family I may be the nosiest person at
The Wall Street Journal and um and I
always want to know what I'm not
supposed to know and and this was this I
mean one of the reasons I was interested
in this is there were so many secrets
and it was tough it was the toughest
reporting I've ever done not necessarily
for good reasons
I covered whitewater at one point I've
covered you know all kinds of bizarre
stories and and and this was the
toughest and it made it more appealing
to me also I never understood why
someone would become a criminal I didn't
get it I wanted to understand why you
would deliberately lie why you would
deliberately you know set up a
fraudulent scheme what would go through
your mind and you know I wanted to tell
this in a compelling way and I didn't
want people to hate Marty Frankel
necessarily I wanted to show sort of all
sides of him I wanted to show you know
sort of the vulnerability of some of
these characters and sort of it sort of
played into my sort of mania for
reporting and gossip I think now you
were
baseball cap along the way for some
reason I did what was on the cap um I
think it said MSNBC yeah actual and why
did you have to work at um this it was
very silly I at one point I finally
decided I have to stop reporting and I
have to start writing and when you're
writing a book like this you have to
keep the momentum up I really wanted to
tell it as a tail
I wanted you have to really stay focused
I wanted to get people inside of rooms I
had to just completely become obsessed
and so I decided I wasn't going to take
the cap off until I finished the book
how long that take I spent five months
writing and the Chocolate fetish the
chocolate fetish was really ugly um
there came a time where at four o'clock
every day I had to have chocolate with
my coffee I also had to wear lipstick
every moment I was writing and on days I
left my lipstick at home I I was in
trouble where did you write it I wrote
it in my office I have a very small
child at home and I could not write it
at home I would never have gotten done
so I wrote it in the temporarily
abandoned offices of The Wall Street
Journal because we've now moved since
September 11th because we were across
the street from the Trade Center how did
the September 11th tragedy affect the
writing of this book um it affected the
writing of the epilogue and the
acknowledgments the book was done the
book was done I was in sort of the final
editing stages on September either ninth
or 10th I spent a huge amount of time
xeroxing the copy edited manuscript so I
could you know go through last changes
and on September 10th I left that on my
desk and on September 11th I was rushing
to the office to deal with that and to
be on the phone with people at Simon &
Schuster and as I watched the plane plow
into the Trade Center do you saw oh yeah
I live just a few blocks from the Trade
Center and worked across this route from
the Trade Center so so just I mean I
actually thought maybe this book
wouldn't
get done because I you know my all my
stuff you know a writer becomes obsessed
with their notes was still in the office
but it was really essentially dawn I
wrote thee I wrote the epilogue and the
acknowledgments for the book on a
borrowed computer with a malfunctioning
spacebar in the advertising offices of
the Wall Street Journal
still in my smokey clothing it was a
bizarrely depressing but from haddock
moment in its own weird horrible way now
when we opened up you said this man in
this picture here is ugly he is you mean
physically ugly or personally ugly or
both um well I'm when I said it I meant
physically ugly um personally he could
be both incredibly attractive or really
ugly I mean this is a man who could one
moment the unbelievably charming and
even gentle and the next moment be
savage and nasty and mean I mean I saw a
little bit of that when he smiled at me
when I told him I was writing a book and
then you know the next moment savagely
asked me um for money he could be both
things and that was and and that was
really what made him so successful you
have under the Greenwich mansion here a
bunch of people I want to go down the
list and just get a little bit of flavor
what they were all about I'm sure
mispronounces is it kotti shucked er que
de chef que de que eh e th e right who
was she
kaida shifter was um a one of marty
Frankel's early lovers when he arrived
in on in Greenwich on and after a bitter
excuse me a bitter war between women she
became an ex-lover and he then enlisted
her to help him meet people to connect
him with um with more sources for money
more sources for important contacts
things like that she became his conduit
to the outside world
she's in Germany now she managed to
escape she's so far escaped
she's been indicted but it's very
unlikely she'll be extradited here how
old is she she is um you know I don't
know how old she is I would guess she's
in her late 30s and I have a source
who's a criminal defense lawyer who was
involved in this who said Keita is my
idol and I said why is Katy your idol he
said she committed the perfect crime
because it's believed that she has
control of one or two million dollars
she may be the person who comes out
ahead and all this Karen Timmons Karen
Timmons was a woman who Marty Frankel
met through a personal ad he rejected
her he did not want her as a romantic
interest she was extremely bitter about
that she would sort of talk as though
Marty wanted to marry her um she was
rather bright and he sort of used her as
an office manager Mona Kim Mona Kim is
another woman and who he met through a
personal ad and he rejected her as well
and she became a clerical um assistant
and she will go to trial with him in
October she is um she is accused of
helping Franco purchase ten million
dollars in gold
Jackie Joo the Jewess bill Ju right
she's a former lover um she um likes
many of his former lovers stuck around I
think they were really together briefly
and she was a clerical assistant she has
not been indicted I'd be very surprised
if she was and when Frankel fled to
Italy and then Germany she fled with him
Miriam Miriam is um an early lover also
in Greenwich um very bright um and she
sort of introduced him to the world of
SNM it's more on the list that I was
going to ask you how do you know all
these women were lovers um
well I admit I was not in the room with
them um but I talked to many people
involved in the house and it was no
there were no secrets in that house I
mean really didn't everybody knew
everything um it was it was a cult when
we were writing about this in the
journal we were afraid to call it a
harem but it was a harem it was
everybody was emotionally entangled with
Marty at one point I was trying to
figure out who had been his lovers and
who hadn't been his lovers and and one
of the women said to me you don't
understand it doesn't matter who was his
lover and who wasn't his lover it was
all the same thing
they all came through personal ads and
they were all in love with him and they
were all emotionally entangled with him
and he and he treated them as though
they were all emotionally tied I don't
hate pronounce it Francis Burge verbs
yes committed suicide she was really
without a doubt the saddest situation in
the house she came through a personal ad
she lived a very tragic life of had
suffered severe depression he was not
interested in her let her on a little
bit and she sort of sunk into a terrible
depression and killed herself in the
mansion that he sort of reserved for
some of his women how'd they find her
Mona can found her um Mona went to look
for Frances one day they were going to
go to an amusement park and when she
couldn't find her immediately started
worrying because everybody everybody in
the house knew that Frances was in love
with Marty and everybody knew she was
depressed and Mona found her hanging
from the bottom of a deck by the way you
you say he's ugly and all these women or
his lovers and did you ever ask any of
them why um I don't think I asked it
quite like that but it was obviously
something that I needed to know because
I needed to try to explain to my readers
why someone this appalling in so many
ways
could be so attractive and and that was
really one of the hardest things in
terms of writing the book on it was
because he was a fabulous listener and
he if he was sitting right here he would
figure out in what ways you were
vulnerable he would figure out your
secret desires within moments and he
would exploit it and for example there
was one woman he had a couple of Russian
women he was involved in in um one of
them badly wanted to be a rock star and
he would be on the phone with her at one
o'clock in the morning listening to her
perform her music over the phone and
that was typical if if cater shifter was
um was an artist um of some you know
some talent I guess but an unsuccessful
artist for some reason she liked to
paint ducks he called her his little
ducky he encouraged her her art she had
social ambitions he got her an apartment
in New York for which he was paying
thousands of dollars a month he had her
um he got or what they called in the
house hot and cold limousine service 24
hour a day limousine service he knew
what these women wanted and he he
catered to it and it's that's important
not just because it makes for a good
tale which I hope it does but also
because that's what he did in the
financial world to in an in his business
world he figured out what people needed
and he fed them he fed them the perfect
line and he ever make any legitimate
money no never
he did one trade early on and he made
eighteen thousand dollars over time he
made a few other trades but they were
not significant tribes so how did he at
what point did he had the most amount of
money available to him at the end
how much wasn't um well or close to the
end I mean he ran through he stole two
hundred and fifteen million dollars
that's pretty clear stole stole now you
know everybody right now is so wrapped
and Enron and people are trying to
understand accounting and they're trying
to understand these partnerships this
was much more simple he bought these
insurance companies using a fraudulent
trust but he bought them and he promised
he told the executives of the insurance
companies that he was going to invest
the assets he's got to ask you yeah how
do you buy an insurance company with a
fraudulent trust he um he created a
trust which he called the Thune or Trust
which was after the the Scandinavian god
sooner which is the same I guess is Thor
and he lied about who put up the money
to buy the trust he said Sonia put up I
think nine hundred thousand dollars at
the time Sonia was making $25,000 a year
he lied and said that a broker who
worked for him briefly you know as a kid
had put up a lot of money and then a
friend of his brothers and put up a lot
of money what was your money in the
trust there was money in the trust what
do you get that he got that money from
excuse-me investors in his second fund
which was called creative partners he he
set up a sort of a mutual fund he got
people to invest in it and then he just
took the money and he bought this small
insurance company in Franklin Tennessee
setting up this fake trust and then he
took the assets of the insurance
companies paid back the insurers the
investors and creative partners and said
he was closing down the fund so we eat a
lot of you know very happy investors in
Toledo because they were paid back but
they didn't know that they were paid
back with money stolen from a little
insurance company in Franklin Tennessee
who is this man in this picture that is
John Hackney John Hackney on a
day-to-day basis ran the insurance
companies starting what year uh starting
I used to know this perfectly I guess
it's 1991 and this is really a perfect
example about how Marty exploited
somebody's needs Frankel knew at that
point that the SEC was going to come
after him he was officially banned from
the securities industry in 1992 he
needed to knew he needed to cleanse his
aim he knew he had to get out of Toledo
so he he answered an ad oddly enough in
the Wall Street Journal on a one of
those little tiny ads somebody offering
to help people by southern banks and
through that guy he met John Hackney and
he figured out that John Hackney was the
perfect front man John Hackney had
worked at banks John Hackney sort of had
a good public persona he was kind of a
good ol boy and John Hackney was
absolutely desperate he was out of work
he'd been laid off from his previous job
he had a beautiful wife she was pregnant
and he needed work so badly that he was
willing to look the other way even
though he knew that Marty Frankel was
setting up a trust using fake names
using you know lying about lying about
about who was putting up the money
here's the picture of John Hackney where
was this taken that was taken in New
Haven Connecticut I guess about a year
ago maybe a little more on the day that
John Hackney pleaded guilty to several
federal charges related to this case
where is he today he is living in
Alabama he is working like a dog trying
to support his family and he is awaiting
sentencing in this case and they're not
sentencing him I would guess because
they are waiting to see how he testifies
at mr. Frankel's trial you create a
picture about John Hackney throughout
this entire book of being in Tennessee
and Marty Frankel being in Toledo or in
Connecticut and they never met until
when until April 1999 they never met
they talked on the phone for hours a day
I mean one of the bizarre questions in
this is what did John Hackney think that
Marty Frankel was doing supposedly Marty
Frankel was a master trader and was
investing the assets of this little
Empire of insurance companies but he
spent huge amounts of time on the phone
just yakking with Hackney they talked
about everything from sex to
to the Civil War I mean one of the
things I sort of enjoyed about this is
the incredible culture clashes here a
Frankel was a Jewish guy from Toledo a
man who lived in his head
John Hackney was a southerner from
Tennessee hadn't met many Jews and was
it was you know was a former frat boy
you know guy with a million friends and
they had zero in common and yet they
were on the phone every day very curious
about each other but they never really
understood each other during those 10
years on those time drew 91 through now
how many insurance companies did he own
what's the most number he ever owned I
think it was seven I always mix it up
whether it's six or seven
what else did Marty Frank alone besides
insurance company that was pretty much
it that was pretty much it but you know
insurance companies have to have
reserves even small insurance companies
throw off a lot of cash he ran through a
lot of it who is this man that is father
Peter Jacobs he is a priest he's a
priest who's been in and out of trouble
with with with the church for most of
his career was he originally Jewish his
father was Jewish um father Jacobs spent
most of his career in New York City
he worked in Harlem at a boys school he
spent a lot of time working with junkies
and [ __ ] um worked very hard by day
and by night father Jacobs party he was
involved with really sort of the
glitterati you know the the literary
sort of glitter our glittery crowd in
New York at one point owned a restaurant
that was frequented by celebrities he's
friends with Norman Mailer he's friends
with Bianca Jagger say he's but he's
attached to the Diocese of Washington
he's attached to the Diocese of
Washington I'm not exactly sure why but
he spent most of his time in New York
he's retired now
he's he's he's pretty elderly and not in
great health
is he under indictment he isn't an under
indictment did he be um I would guess
not but I'm not sure um he he helps
Marty Frankel there's there's no
question about that I mean there's there
are so many people involved in the
scheme who walk a very fine line between
legality and illegality and and I think
that's actually sort of one of the
lessons of this book I mean I wrote it
to be a good tale but there are some
real lessons and one of them I think is
just how many people are in business in
the professions really walk this very
gray line and how many people define
truth differently than a lot of us do
had Walter Cronkite get in this Walter
Cronkite was a friend of is well was a
friend of Father Jacob's father Jacob's
met Marty Frankel and Marty Frankel said
I want to set up a charity and I'm going
to have the charity by insurance
companies and the profits will go to
check will go to the profits from the
insurance companies will go to charity
and father Jacobs tried to get his
friend Walter Cronkite involved and
basically Walter Cronkite said no he
probably in retrospect should have said
it a little bit more firmly but he was
on the phone with father Jacobsen and he
you know he he father Jacob swill same
old will you help us identify charities
and and mr. Cronkite made it very very
clear that he did not want to be on any
boards he did not want to be a member of
any organizations and I think what he
basically said was you don't yell yack
with you on the phone and at one point
somebody from one of these organizations
one of you know Frankel's charities
called Cronkite and Cronkite reiterated
he said I don't want to be involved and
calls father Jacobs and said no I don't
want to be involved but that didn't
matter because Marty Frankel still used
to
and some of his promotional materials
and said that Lee Iacocca and Walter
Cronkite have agreed to be on our
advisory board advisory board for one of
the charity the charity what was a
connection to the Pope what was the
connection to the Vatican um
that's another good question without a
completely clear answer um father Jacobs
had retired to Rome he sort of divided
his time between New York and Rome and
he had many Vatican ties and he offered
to help Frankel make connections with
the Vatican and in fact did and a lawyer
named Tom Boland who is a former law
partner of Roy Cohn and is a religious a
very village a deeply religious man on
on Marty Frankel's behest went and
negotiated with the Vatican and tried to
get the the the Vatican to back the fake
charity and Bolin did not realize it was
a fake charity and he met with very
senior people at the Vatican he had a
series of meetings with people the
Vatican who were extremely interested in
doing business with this man who they
knew him as David Ross the one thing
they balked at on and and not
immediately but pretty quickly was they
did not want to be in the insurance
business and so Frankel frustrated
basically lied he got another Catholic
foundation called the monitor
ecclesiasticus foundation on which did
have ties to the Vatican had a Vatican
bank account and did have ties to agree
to be involved with Saint Francis and in
fact the head of that foundation
Monsignor Kola Giovanni signed several
fake affidavits one of which said that
the Holy See was providing funds for st.
Francis the Monsignor knows fake the I
believe firmly that the Monsignor knew
that that wasn't true one of the one of
the affidavits said that that that the
monitor ecclesiasticus
had given a billion dollars to Saint
Francis and monitor ecclesiasticus is a
very small foundation which puts out a
journal of canon law he must have known
that wasn't correct month the Monsignor
has at various times said different
things about these affidavits once he
said oh his name was forged but other
times most of the times he has agreed he
signed it and he has been arrested and
it's unclear he was visiting he's based
in Rome he was visiting his elderly
sister in Cleveland and was picked up by
by US law enforcement officials and is
in the u.s. waiting the disposition of
his case go back to how you buy
insurance companies through a charity or
through a foundation or well first he
bought them through through this trust
but then his idea was that he was going
to buy them through this charity and he
um basically it failed he wanted to buy
a lot more insurance companies he wanted
to be AIG he wanted to be you know a
billion dollar company and he enlisted
the help of Aegon Gump and got in many
doors
I mean people you know people would hear
that Bob Strauss and akin gump
represented these entities and I won't
bore you with the names of all these
sort of entities he was using to try to
buy the insurance companies besides
Saint Francis on the doors swung open
here's a picture of Bob Strauss in here
today how long did the the lawyer or the
law firm support him and when did they
find out that there might be something
wrong with this man well they did not
find out that there was anything wrong
until um he fled akin gump was most
active for Frankel's entities in late 98
but they you know they they hadn't
resigned the account or anything
and when Frankel disappeared in May I
can jump was pretty worried about where
he'd gone to and was and was trying to
figure out where where he'd gone because
they were still you know to some degree
involved so here's a guy operating with
the Vatican ties
the Bob Strauss ties in Washington any
other ties of significance the Walter
Cronkite lee iaccoca names were all
bandied about those were that those were
the main one Jimmy Carter way he um
along the way he would establish other
ties for example when Tennessee
regulators started poking around
he hired former senator Matthews who's a
lawyer
Harlan Master Harlan Matthews who I
guess filled in a vice president Gore's
Senate seat when he became vice
president and he so he had that credible
person on behind him former lieutenant
governor Mississippi that's right Brad
died briefly represented him and one of
the more curious episodes of the book
and one I we actually wish I knew more
about was when Frankel and and his
people were preparing to meet with the
regulator's in Mississippi near the end
when things are about to fall apart
Brad died got very nervous and he got up
closed his briefcase and walk out he
just he smelled he clearly and I don't
know this perfect
he clearly smelled something bad and
thought I don't want to have anything to
do with this seem to me I wrote down two
names there are two people in this thing
that started decoding one was an
insurance and Commissioner investigator
in Mississippi and the other was the
security man up in Connecticut right
I mean explained of all along the way
people listening this hearing this what
happens when somebody comes to me how do
you know that somebody's being honest
and when this thing as a whole this
whole situation was a fraud who was the
first person to catch on here that there
was something squaring off you screw a
screw up going on here well one of the
scary things about this story I mean
really the big cautionary tale of the of
this story is how many times people
tried to to blow the whistle on Marty
Frankel really among the first people to
do it was his nemesis John Schulte who
went to the SEC and
one of the things John Schulte did was
he hired a private investigator to go
through Frankel's garbage and he would
keep you know feeding the what he was
finding to to regulators early on to
investors sued Frankel and their lawyers
a law firm in Toledo called shoemaker
loop they took on this case of these
investors even though it wasn't a big
money maker for them because they were
so outraged they wrote to the SEC and
said we know you're investigating him
this is early on in 92
but he's added again you have to stop
him nothing happened and then there was
this investigator in Greenwich years
later where Frankel's neighbors were
they didn't like him they there were
cars in and out that were guards they
were worried about guns they were
worried about drugs probably
unnecessarily their kids were in the
neighborhood they were worried about you
know that their kids were going to have
problems and they hired a private
investigator a former FBI guy on and
within twenty nine hours he had figured
out Frankel's real name that he'd been
banned from the securities industry that
he was probably violating the ban and
that he was breaking the law he went to
the SEC he went to the US Attorney's
office and you know although there's
some signs that an investigation was
started nothing really came to fruition
but in the middle of all this by the way
is chapter six in the middle of this
there's chapter six which I just think
of I call it domestic bliss it was
anything but that because it was mostly
about all the women bickering in the
household but it's about it's basically
you know the chapter about Franklin sex
and his week growing an odd obsession
with SNM sex and his relationship with
in relationships with these women and
how it's a miracle he got anything done
because of all the bickering in the
household and all and all that this sort
of sexually charged and infused
atmosphere of this house S&M sex means
what sadomasochistic sex what is it he
got pleasure from hurting women and
the solicited bed partners who got
pleasure from being hurt I mean
everything from from whips to you know
riding crops to tying people up to weird
clips to you know it was painful sex
somebody had to tell you about this
because it's rather descriptive um yes
yes I I interviewed a by interviewed a
bunch of women who had lived in the
house and as I said there were no
secrets and there was you know at times
more than one person in the bed and
there were videotapes made oh did you
see him you know I didn't see them I I
just I have to admit my stomach wasn't
strong enough to actually ask to see the
tapes one of them I actually I'd heard
about and then actually located and
another one I think has sort of vanished
but um but so you know there was there
were plenty of people who had seen some
of these videotapes there were plenty of
people who'd witnessed the sex there
were plenty of participants in it and
there were no secrets in that house what
would you say was your number one source
of information for this not just for
this chapter but for the whole book and
if he went back and looked over
everything you did always number one oh
definitely my number one source were the
interviews with the people involved and
you know I can't name them all because a
lot of them you know we're very worried
about being indicted some of them were
indicted as I was working on the book
and defense lawyers usually tell their
clients don't talk to the press and I
actually you know I've covered law long
enough I know something about this and I
actually think that sometimes that's
good advice and sometimes it's terrible
advice and and I did many many
interviews with the people involved and
that's absolutely my primary source of
information I mean there were also court
documents and indictments along the way
how many places did you go that he lived
or worked in or did you go to the
mansion I went to the mansion I wasn't
able to go inside the mansion
I interviewed a lot of people who were
who were I interviewed a lot of people
who were inside obviously but I did go
to the mansion I spent time in Greenwich
I spent a lot of time in Toledo I went
to Germany I went to Franklin Tennessee
where they insurance companies were were
based where else did I go um I was in
Washington DC
I um you know I went mostly I didn't go
to Mississippi where I should have gone
some of the action takes place there and
I did that over the phone and I didn't
go to Italy and I should have gone to
Italy but for a moment go back to that
Mississippian mm-hmm buried in the inlet
the Insurance Commissioners Office
mm-hmm the state government who found
something how'd that work um well near
the end there were two sets of
regulators who became suspicious one
unsung hero of this is a guy named Billy
Lovelady who was the Tennessee auditor
who wrote a who wrote a a memo to his
bosses saying that he worried that the
assets of these insurance companies were
being looted and he used the word looted
and he actually figured the whole thing
out and he wrote a memo to his bosses
the insurance commissioner and other
people in the department and it fell
into a deep bureaucratic hole nothing
happened how did he figure it out and
nobody else could
looking at the books um he looked at the
books and then he realized that the
assets were being managed by something
called Liberty national securities which
was Frankel's brokerage firm and he went
to public records realized that Liberty
national securities was a tiny tiny
entity with like a capitalization of
something like fifty nine thousand
dollars and realized how can this tiny
firm be be trading all this all this
well you know these these hundreds of
millions of dollars in assets it just
didn't seem right to him I don't want to
be unfair here but I want to
go back to the Harlan Matthews example
and I tell me what I've gone too far
with this but the impression you get
when you're reading is that he hired all
these officials former officials Harlan
Matthews former United States Senator
the fellow was a former lieutenant
governor of Mississippi and their job
was to get into the state governments
into the Commissioner's offices and
prevent things from happening that would
save these insurance companies from
being exposed did it work
um it did work I have to say it did work
I mean ultimately it failed but it
worked for a while definitely I would
say in Tennessee and you know there
might be officials in Tennessee who
would argue with this um they they were
able to stall they were definitely able
to stall um
did they know they were doing something
illegal oh no no no I mean how is
somebody at the Roberts jobs law firm
going to know if a client comes in
whether they're legal or illegal did
they make a mistake um I think I
actually do think that the egg and dump
people made some mistakes do you talk to
him um I can't tell you who I talked to
for this or not for the most part but on
at one point Frankel sent a bunch of
binders filled with material silly
material for the most part to Akin Gump
I mean and and it included pictures of
father Jacobs and the Pope and father
Jakes of Jacob's mother with the Pope's
Christmas tree things that were very
unbusinesslike and in that in one of
those binders was a document that
Frankel had created and it made it look
as though it was an akin gump document
drafted by Akin Gump lawyers and in that
document was the document that said that
um that a Walter Cronkite and Lee
Iacocca were on the advisory board and
the akin gump people didn't notice um I
I don't I really believe that the akin
gump people did not know that there was
anything illegal but should they have
noticed should they flip through the
binders and said wow that says it's
written by us we didn't write that
who is this woman that is Cynthia
Allison she is one of Marty's women
um she is one of the most more pathetic
of Marty Frankel's women I would say she
they met through a personal ad he was
not interested in her they did not have
a romantic and a relationship she badly
wanted to have a romantic relationship
with him and one day said something like
I'd like to kill him or something like
that
a sentiment by the way that a lot of
people had at various times he could be
very annoying and Frankel got wind of it
and banned her from the house even
posted her picture at the guard booth to
make sure she didn't come back into into
the the compound when he fled um he fled
with two women Mona cannon Jackie Chu
and they wanted to go home fled to
Germany yeah and first to Italy and the
only woman who would agree to come and
be with Marty on the lam with Cynthia
Alison because we're almost out of time
there's a final picture of Marty Frankel
in Germany for those who join late where
is he and when's the trial and what what
would he get if everything if he was
found guilty of everything um he is in
Rhode Island he is awaiting trial in
which will be in October in federal
court in New Haven and I don't know what
he'll get um seasoned prison in Rhode
Island in Rhode Island
mom said Connecticut I'm sorry I do in
Rhode Island um I don't know what he'll
get um but it's gonna be a lot of years
I mean I would think assuming he's
convicted of what what will he be
convicted he could be convicted of
securities fraud of racketeering of wire
fraud Villisca it's a pretty long list
his bodyguard was just sentenced to 10
years Ross David Ross and I'm assuming
that um that Marty Frankel will be if he
is convicted will serve a lot more time
than that he could spend most of the
rest of his life in jail I would think
Ellen John Pollock has been our guest
she's a Wall Street Journal reporter and
this is the book it's called the
Pretender about Martin Frankel thank
very much thank you